egging it's your old pal Sam here with
some exciting news and things to talk
about regarding Avengers endgame today's
video will be all about your favorite
moment from the trailer that's right
when it's revealed that Clint Barton has
been murdering people in Japan woohoo
he's handling this happening well what's
with the new digs what's he doing being
sad in the rain did something happen to
his family pin to the comic book lore
and search for those answers and more
but first for the warning for MCU films
all of them in Marvel Comics all of them
and the hit ABC show lost they were in
heaven the whole time except when they
weren't anyways let's kick it off with
Clint's new outfit Wow snazzy love the
all-black look with a little gold trim
ooh yum yum what we're looking at here
is the emcee whose first appearance of
Ronan or rather new addition to the
Marvel Comics universe Clint has taken
up the mantle of Ronan in Marvel Comics
in the past but it's made its rounds
with other heroes the Ronan mantle first
appeared in New Avengers number 11 in
November 2005 but originally it was worn
by Maya Lopez aka eko eko is this new
character who could mirror the abilities
and fighting skills when she sees other
heroes fighting pretty cool fun fact
Brian Michael Bendis created the Ronan
persona as a fun way to reveal that Matt
Murdock had secretly joined the New
Avengers but due to upcoming stories in
the daredevil solo series they swapped
out the story and introduced EKKO then
took up the mantle following the events
of Avengers disassembled where he died
and house of M where he was resurrected
hiding his return from the public
Aleksey shafts Kitab and Erik Brooks
have gone the run in persona and in the
Ultimate Universe run was one of Mark
specters personalities aka moon night
that's far too complicated to get into
but all the costumes are dope asked for
abilities besides looking cooler than
the classic Hawkeye outfit zing big fan
of this one though nothing really
changes between the user and the outfit
just that ronan is more likely to be
fighting with a sword than anything else
definitely down for Moore's Ward's in my
Avengers films now what could roaring be
doing in Japan well a ronin is a samurai
without a master or a wandering man so
possibly Clint created this mantle while
in Japan with his family or maybe he
just fled to Japan after the snap inning
either way I appreciate what looks to be
the writers attempting to tie that name
of that character back to the region
that it originated but now on to the big
question why is Clint wearing this Ronin
soo
well my theory is that after the events
of civil war in the sokovia accords
blocking from acting out as Hawkeye boom
nice plug he's created a new persona to
go out into the world and deal out
justice if that was what he is doing out
there in the rain also I think the MCU
has done enough leg worked for this
transition to make sense at least skill
wise we've seen Clinton go up against
numerous foes in the past with
hand-to-hand combat and even turning his
boat into a sort of staff or ass ward
like in the airport fight scene in civil
war but again why this transformation
well I feel like the story is pretty
clear can kind of see the pieces and put
him together yourself but it seems like
Clint has lost his family during the
snap and now he is distraught and
without a reason for being very similar
to a samurai without a master
you can't Ronin there you go now my
theory like I said is that he's been
dealing out justice all over the world
possibly taking out criminal
organizations that have been taking
advantage of this apocalyptic situation
getting some serious punish survives but
hey what do you guys think I could see
Clint aka Ronan becoming a bit of a
wild-card in this situation in Avengers
endgame and I'm excited to see how this
all concludes what do you guys think of
this Ronan persona would you like to see
EKKO possibly pop up in the MCU I know I
would give this video a like and
subscribe to new rockstars for more
content like this but also check out my
show only stupid answers you'll dig it
you can also follow me at Sam bash or on
Twitter and I'll see you again next time
[Music]